how do you think the audience can tell
though that there's maybe certain cuts
that have been held back suppose we'll
take the goody-two-shoes so oh my oh
isn't this person great and all this
stuff but really then their backbiting
and doing all this stuff behind the
scenes well how does this audience know
this the audience knows it because it's
not a reaction that you would have to
what was actually happening in front of
you if I see two people fighting in
front of me I'm not going to say oh my
i'm probably going to yell at them you
guys i can offer just get involved to
the point where i'm meeting the energy
level of what's happening in the room
what i have to use a cutaway of you you
know from five minutes before or five
minutes after just like oh because
you're you're not going to cooperate
with me if i make you look bad gotcha
okay then you're going to look in
authentic in the final product and
people are not going to relate to you
and you're not going to have a chance to
break out or be someone who returns for
subsequent season there's a character
have to be liked to be brought back I
think the character has to be liked or
absolutely despised to come back and in
order to in order to create a villain by
the way that is likable in their way
there's no such thing as somebody who is
all bad or all good you have to shed a
little cracks you have to show the
vulnerability you have to show what's
motivating that person to do what it is
that they're doing no one in reality
shows is just a hundred percent awful a
hundred percent of the time because
you'd get tired of watching them and it
just you know turns into a Lucy sketch
where somebody is just all one thing you
know it's like I'm the blustery bank
manager or you know that nobody is that
everybody everybody is on some level you
know motivated by whatever it is that's
driving I'm making no sense right now no
no I get it because you're talking about
this three-dimensional character so so
they can't they're resting state it's
not always a clustering and you're
moaning what that is that's the thing it
is your your villains or your village
just like your hero is just like any
part
Vince in the show have to have multiple
dimensions otherwise you don't buy into
them you don't understand you look at
the great the Great villains in scripted
they're motivated by something they
could be motivated by greed but they can
also be motivated by you know while I
this thing happened to me 15 years ago
and now I want revenge even though it
might not be you know that it you're a
terrible person who's exacting revenge
but at least we know what's motivating
you you have to have the same thing for
a villain in reality shows
you